nous sommes avec Fabrice Fratini
professeur de mathématiques et
représentant syndical CGT au lycée
Gutenberg Créteil bonjour et merci
d'être direct avec nous ce matin sur RTL
une rentrée chamboulé parle au micro
avez-vous déjà écho d'élèves absent
qu'en est-il également des professeurs
ce matin
bonjour oui il y a
des messages là maintenant avec avec
avec
[Musique]
alors justement la veille de cette
rentrée on a appris ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire qui doit être appliquée est-ce
que ses règles sont suffisantes est-ce
que les établissements scolaires sont
préparées aussi
nous avons appris ce nouveau protocole
sanitaire hier tout d'abord dans Le
Parisien dans un premier temps donc pour
être prêt ce sera assez compliqué
c'est
depuis que Delta d'avoir
le salaire de plus en plus au départ
nous avons une fermeture de classe
[Musique]
et derrière nous allons faire court dans
des bocaux acolytes qui sont souvent
avec les températures c'est très
compliqué
donc voilà
justement on parle beaucoup qui protège
contre le
signaler aujourd'hui
même si on est
à l'école est-ce qu'il faudrait voilà
généralisé ce fameux un masque FFP2 au
lycée notamment
oui c'est évident
population générale
[Musique]
on a parlé justement de ses élèves qui
risque d'être isolé quelques jours vous
parlez également du bac blanc qui a qui
approche comment ça va se passer
justement pour cet élève qui se retrouve
chez eux est-ce qu'ils ont moyen de de
suivre ses cours
à distance
là aussi il y a toujours cette semaine à
préparation
je vois pas comment une enseignante
dédoubler faire c'est en même temps
à distance et
[Musique]
et
donc c'est une course c'est une course à
ne pas perdre du temps avec le terminal
mais
en tout cas
merci beaucoup Fabrice d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques et
représentant syndical CGT
à Créteil